Some of the best films are subjective, meaning
their stories can be interpreted a number
of different ways depending on the viewer's
own experiences.
But an excessively ambiguous ending or a sudden
shift in tone can leave audiences scratching
their heads in confusion.
Don't worry — we're here to explain some
of the most baffling movie endings that don't
mean exactly what you think they do.
Beware, however: There are spoilers ahead.
In Bruges
In this darkly comic morality tale, assassins
Ray and Ken are sent to Bruges to lay low
after a hit gone wrong.
By the end of the film, half the cast is dead,
and Ray is being carried away to an ambulance,
pondering the nature of mortality — and
Hell.
Viewers are ultimately left to wonder whether
or not he survived the film's bloody climax.
In one reading of the film, however, this
question doesn’t matter, because Ray is
— wait for it — already in Purgatory.
Earlier in the film, Ken takes Ray on an arts
tour of Bruges, whereupon the two view Hieronymus
Bosch's "The Last Judgement" painting.
It's the one segment of the tour that Ray
actually seems invested in, and it sparks
a conversation about Purgatory, a realm which
Ray describes as …
"kinda like in betweeney one.
You're not really f-----, but you weren't
all that great either.
The final scene of the movie mirrors Bosch's
painting, as a fatally wounded Ray looks up
at mysterious animal-faced creatures — really
just actors in costume — while he wonders
what punishments await him.
He thinks Bruges is Hell, but maybe it's just
a place for people not quite bad enough for
the real thing.
Total Recall
1990's mind-bending Total Recall has become
a cult classic in the decades since its release.
Adapted from sci-fi author Philip K. Dick's
short story "We Can Remember It for You Wholesale,"
the film centers around Douglas Quaid, a construction
worker from the year 2084.
Though, Quaid may or may not also be a secret
agent with memory loss… and a rebel involved
in a war on Mars.
The film continually encourages audiences
to question the reality of what they're watching.
Are you actually seeing Quaid finish his secret
mission, or is this part of the Recall procedure?
One moment near the end of the film seems
to suggest most of the film took place in
his noggin.
Early in the movie, before the Recall procedure
has started, a lab tech reading Quaid's dreams
notes that they include "a blue sky on Mars."
While the similarities between the character
Melina and the woman in Quaid's dreams can
be explained away by his buried memories,
the lab techs are clearly surprised by his
conception of a Mars with a blue sky.
When the movie ends with Quaid and Melina
looking over the Martian sky, newly blue from
oxygen after saving the planet, it's the biggest
clue to the viewer that they're watching a
dream.
Get Out
The story of Chris, a black man meeting his
white girlfriend's parents for the first time,
Get Out borders on dark comedy at times — but
the genre-bending flick goes full horror when
the family's chilling secret comes to light.
By the end of the movie, Chris has escaped
the grounds of the Armitage mansion with his
friend Rod after killing the family and setting
their secret brain-swapping laboratory ablaze.
The end of the movie sees Rod telling Chris
that he can "Consider this situation ''
handled."
But Chris doesn't respond to Rod — instead,
he stares dejectedly into the dashboard as
they drive away, leaving his girlfriend, Rose,
to die in the street behind them.
While it's cathartic to see the hero of the
film survive, defeat the villains, and drive
off with his friend, the ending is a bit darker
than people realize: Chris knows the situation
isn't "handled."
Logan, a victim of the procedure shown earlier
in the film, is still being mind-controlled,
and a few dozen old, white gentry are still
stealing black bodies and minds.
In the alternate ending, these tragic realities
are made much more explicit.
Chris winds up in jail for the murder of the
Armitage family, with no way to prove his
innocence or expose their crimes.
He tells Rod that at least he "stopped it"
as he's led to his cell, where he's surrounded
by other black men.
In both endings, racism isn't vanquished just
because Chris is able to defeat the rich body-snatchers;
they were just one particularly repugnant
example of a systemic—and very real—horror.
Fargo
Fargo ranks among the most straightforward
of the Coen brothers' films; it's the story
of a small town crime, a greedy little man
with a massive ego, and a witty sheriff with
a good heart.
Still, viewers are more likely to remember
Steve Buscemi's performance — and his gruesome
disposal in the wood chipper — than the
movie's quiet, touching ending.
In the film's final scene, Sheriff Marge is
shown laying in bed with her husband Norm,
who laments that his mallard painting was
passed over for the first-class stamp contest.
Margie says she proud of him, adding …
"Heck Normie you know we're doing pretty good."
The subtle ending completely encapsulates
the core themes of the movie, refuting the
naked greed of nearly every other character.
From Jerry, whose ambitions lead to the deaths
of nearly half a dozen people, to Mike's desperate
desire for Marge to believe that his life
is more interesting — and tragic — than
it seems, the characters in Fargo sow chaos
when they focus on what they want rather than
what they have.
Marge's confirmation of the good life she
and her husband have built together changes
the movie from a comedy-drama into a morality
play, reminding the audience to be grateful
for what they have.
Shutter Island
Shutter Island, the Martin Scorsese adaptation
of the novel of the same name, is a period
thriller boasting a murderer's row of talent
including Leonardo DiCaprio, Mark Ruffalo,
and Ben Kingsley.
In 1954, U.S. Marshal Teddy Daniels investigates
an insane asylum following the escape of notorious
murderer Andrew Laeddis while dealing with
the suspicious Dr. Cawley and the disappearance
of his partner, Chuck.
The central twist of the movie drew most of
the audience's attention.
Basically, Teddy Daniels is actually Andrew
Laeddis, acting out a fantasy to restore his
memories following the murder of his wife
after she drowned their children years ago.
But it was the enigmatic final line of the
movie that has confused audiences well beyond
the credits.
Teddy, seemingly regressed back to his original
delusion that he is a U.S. Marshal, asks Chuck:
"Which would be worse?
To live as a monster or to die a good man?"
According to Scorsese's psychiatric advisor
on the film, James Gilligan, the line represents
Teddy faking his own regression, choosing
this path to atone for the murder of his wife.
The last moments of the film can be interpreted
as if Teddy were actually saying, "I feel
too guilty to go on living.
I'm not going to actually end my life, but
I'm going to vicariously do it by handing
myself over to these people who are going
to lobotomize me."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!